you just have to
deal with it it is what it is khloe
kardashian has a message for her haters
after this post inspired the phrase
chicken feet hands
we all want to be cute over here okay
after chloe posted that shot where her
fingers look extra long she shared this
one a promo image from her jeans brand
and at least one follower trolled her in
the comments section calling out coco
for hiding her hands after all the mean
messages about her first pick but chloe
clapped right back telling the fan
that's totally not the case quote lol
never my hands are beautiful baby i
don't take it too seriously because
god only knows if i looked at their
photos what they look like and in real
life i also don't care like it is what
it is so yeah chloe case seemingly
paying no mind to the haters she's dealt
with similar speculation in the past
like when she shared these snaps her
exaggerated limbs inspiring a ton of
photoshop fail comments at the time
chloe blamed the distorted look on her
camera settings and went about her
business
and when chloe's not monitoring her
comment section she's working on her
fitness working out is one of my new
obsession healthy obsessions along with
those controversial picks chloe's been
showing off her impressive gym routine
check out these before and after pics
yeah that's just three months of
progress from the mom of one i love to
work out and i love to just like that's
my selfish time of course we know coco
loves a good revenge body moment and
she's fresh off a split from nba star
tristan thompson my revenge is not
towards one person it's more for
everyone who was so cruel to me and
really shunned me i have revenge on that
and revenge almost on my old self it's
almost like in pretty woman when they
were like we don't
you can't afford that dress
big mistake big
big mistake
big huge we imagine chloe's hitting the
gym to de-stress too in december news
broke that tristan fathered a child with
another woman while still dating chloe
chloe hasn't spoken out about the
scandal but we know she likes to focus
on herself instead of the drama during
tough times it's just i think a little
too toxic for me to keep reliving stuff
like that so i stay off social after
weeks of dodging questions about the
baby tristan finally confirmed he is the
father and issued a public apology to
chloe but a source tells et that the nba
star's message didn't help the situation
and that chloe is feeling pretty crushed
i'm someone who i do like to put my
relationships as a priority and i try to
make i really try to make that work now
our source says chloe is all about
bettering herself by working out eating
healthy and focusing on her mind body
and soul she's getting back on her
a-game i really think i'm in a good
place but i think working on your
personal growth internally is something
that will be a forever
mission and i always want to evolve and
grow and mature emotionally
because that's how we become better
people
you